In the last lecture we learned how to build
combinational logic circuits given a functional
specification that told us how output values
were related to the current values of the
inputs.
But here's a simple device we can't build
with combinational logic.
The device has a light that serves as the
output and push button that serves as the
input.
If the light is off and we push the button,
the light turns on.
If the light is on and we push the button,
the light turns off.
What makes this circuit different from the
combinational circuits we've discussed so
far?
The biggest difference is that the device's
output is not function of the device's *current*
input value.
The behavior when the button is pushed depends
on what has happened in the past:
odd numbered pushes turn the light on, even
numbered pushes turn the light off.
The device is "remembering" whether the last
push was an odd push or an even push so it
will behave according to the specification
when the next button push comes along.
Devices that remember something about the
history of their inputs are said to have state.
The second difference is more subtle.
The push of the button marks an event in time:
we speak of the state before the push ("the
light is on") and state after the push ("the
light is off").
It's the transition of the button from un-pushed
to pushed that we're interested in, not the
whether the button is currently pushed or
not.
The device's internal state is what allows
it to produce different outputs even though
it receives the same input.
A combinational device can't exhibit this
behavior since its outputs depends only on
the current values of the input.
Let's see how we'll incorporate the notion
of device state into our circuitry.
We'll introduce a new abstraction of a memory
component that will store the current state
of the digital system we want to build.
The memory component stores one or more bits
that encode the current state of the system.
These bits are available as digital values
on the memory component's outputs, shown here
as the wire marked "Current State".
The current state, along with the current
input values, are the inputs to a block of
combinational logic that produces two sets
of outputs.
One set of outputs is the next state of the
device, encoded using the same number of bits
as the current state.
The other set of outputs are the signals that
serve as the outputs of the digital system.
The functional specification for the combinational
logic (perhaps a truth table, or maybe a set
of Boolean equations)
specifies how the next state and system outputs
are related to the current state and current
inputs.
The memory component has two inputs: a LOAD
control signal that indicates when to replace
the current state with the next state,
and a data input that specifies what the next
state should be.
Our plan is to periodically trigger the LOAD
control, which will produce a sequence of
values for the current state.
Each state in the sequence is determined from
the previous state and the inputs at the time
the LOAD was triggered.
Circuits that include both combinational logic
and memory components are called sequential
logic.
The memory component has a specific capacity
measured in bits.
If the memory component stores K bits, that
puts an upper bound of 2^K on the number of
possible states since the state of the device
is encoded using the K bits of memory.
So, we'll need to figure out how to build
a memory component that can loaded with new
values now and then.
That's the subject of this chapter.
We'll also need a systematic way of designing
sequential logic to achieve the desired sequence
of actions.
That's the subject of the next chapter.
We've been representing bits as voltages,
so we might consider using a capacitor to
store a particular voltage.
The capacitor is passive two-terminal device.
The terminals are connected to parallel conducting
plates separated by insulator.
Adding charge Q to one plate of the capacitor
generates a voltage difference V between the
two plate terminals.
Q and V are related by the capacitance C of
the capacitor: Q = CV.
When we add charge to a capacitor by hooking
a plate terminal to higher voltage, that's
called "charging the capacitor".
And when we take away charge by connecting
the plate terminal to a lower voltage, that's
called "discharging the capacitor".
So here's how a capacitor-based memory device
might work.
One terminal of the capacitor is hooked to
some stable reference voltage.
We'll use an NFET switch to connect the other
plate of the capacitor to a wire called the
bit line.
The gate of the NFET switch is connected to
a wire called the word line.
To write a bit of information into our memory
device, drive the bit line to the desired
voltage (i.e., a digital 0 or a digital 1).
Then set the word line HIGH, turning on the
NFET switch.
The capacitor will then charge or discharge
until it has the same voltage as the bit line.
At this point, set the word line LOW, turning
off the NFET switch and isolating the capacitor's
charge on the internal plate.
In a perfect world, the charge would remain
on the capacitor's plate indefinitely.
At some later time, to access the stored information,
we first charge the bit line to some intermediate
voltage.
Then set the word line HIGH, turning on the
NFET switch, which connects the charge on
the bit line to the charge on the capacitor.
The charge sharing between the bit line and
capacitor will have some small effect on the
charge on the bit line and hence its voltage.
If the capacitor was storing a digital 1 and
hence was at a higher voltage,
charge will flow from the capacitor into the
bit line, raising the voltage of the bit line.
If the capacitor was storing a digital 0 and
was at lower voltage, charge will flow from
the bit line into the capacitor, lowering
the voltage of the bit line.
The change in the bit line's voltage depends
on the ratio of the bit line capacitance to
C, the storage capacitor's capacitance, but
is usually quite small.
A very sensitive amplifier, called a sense
amp, is used to detect that small change and
produce a legal digital voltage as the value
read from the memory cell.
Whew!
Reading and writing require a whole sequence
of operations, along with carefully designed
analog electronics.
The good news is that the individual storage
capacitors are quite small.
In modern integrated circuits we can fit billions
of bits of storage on relatively inexpensive
chips called dynamic random-access memories,
or DRAMs for short.
DRAMs have a very low cost per bit of storage.
The bad news is that the complex sequence
of operations required for reading and writing
takes a while, so access times are relatively
slow.
And we have to worry about carefully maintaining
the charge on the storage capacitor in the
face of external electrical noise.
The really bad news is that the NFET switch
isn't perfect and there's a tiny amount leakage
current across the switch even when it's officially
off.
Over time that leakage current can have a
noticeable impact on the stored charge, so
we have to periodically refresh the memory
by reading and re-writing the stored value
before the leakage has corrupted the stored
information.
In current technologies, this has to be done
every 10ms or so.
Hmm.
Maybe we can get around the drawbacks of capacitive
storage by designing a circuit that uses feedback
to provide a continual refresh of the stored
information…
Here's a circuit using combinational inverters
hooked in a positive feedback loop.
If we set the input of one of the inverters
to a digital 0, it will produce a digital
1 on its output.
The second inverter will then a produce a
digital 0 on its output, which is connected
back around to the original input.
This is a stable system and these digital
values will be maintained, even in the presence
of noise, as long as this circuitry is connected
to power and ground.
And, of course, it's also stable if we flip
the digital values on the two wires.
The result is a system that has two stable
configurations, called a bi-stable storage
element.
Here's the voltage transfer characteristic
showing how V_OUT and V_IN of the two-inverter
system are related.
The effect of connecting the system's output
to its input is shown by the added constraint
that V_IN equal V_OUT.
We can then graphically solve for values of
V_IN and V_OUT that satisfy both constraints.
There are three possible solutions where the
two curves intersect.
The two points of intersection at either end
of the VTC are stable in the sense that small
changes in V_IN (due, say, to electrical noise),
have no effect on V_OUT.
So the system will return to its stable state
despite small perturbations.
The middle point of intersection is what we
call metastable.
In theory the system could balance at this
particular V_IN/V_OUT voltage forever,
but the smallest perturbation will cause the
voltages to quickly transition to one of the
stable solutions.
Since we're planing to use this bi-stable
storage element as our memory component, we'll
need to figure out how to avoid getting the
system into this metastable state.
More on this in the next chapter.
Now let's figure out how to load new values
into our bi-stable storage element.